والزياره لكم للقاهره
الصله اللي تجمعنا في الحقيقه عبر السنوات
ونقاتنا جعلت فيما بيننا علاقه شخصيه
اقدرها واحترم
تواصلي معك عبر الفتره الماضيه
واكرر مره اخرى التعازي في ضحايا
الزلزال المدمر
اتمنى
الرحمه للمفقودين وشفاء العاجل للمصابين
واتوجه لك بجزيل الشكر على الرعايه
والاهتماموها له خلال زيارتي وتفقدي
لمواقع زلزال
استقبلتني بحفاوه وبالغه وفرت من وقت وقت
طويل بشكرك على هذا ولكن هو ماذا توقعه في
اطار علاقه اخويه
نصيحه تربط بين شعبي البلدين هذه العلاقه
ممتده في التاريخ
ونعتز بها كثيرا
ونسعد بان نطلق
انا وانت هذه المشاورات لتكون
المسار لاستعاده تطبيع العلاقات فيما بين
البلدين في كافه المناحي
وبدء مرحله جديده يكون لها وقعها واثارها
الايجابي انا شعبي
وتؤدي الى تحقيق مزيد من الاستقرار في
منطقه تامر
تبحثنا
لما يزيد عن ساعتين من الزمن تم خلال
مباحثاتنا تناول كافه قضايا العلاقات
الثنائيه
الاوضاع الاقليميه
التحديات التي نواجهها
وكانت وحثات معمقه
وشفافه وصريحه بحكم
اهميه ما نراه من اهميه لهذه العلاقات
بالتاكيد هناك اراده سياسيه وتوجيهات من
قبل رئيسيه البلدين عندما اجتمع في الدوحه
وتكليف وزيراي الخارجيه بمسؤوليه
اطلاق المسار
للوصول الى التطبيع الكامل للعلاقات بعد
تطورات السنوات الماضيه ونحن بالتاكيد
ننظر نحو الامام ننظر الى كل ما يستطيع ان
يعود بالنفع على البلدين خلال المراحل
القادمه
واثقين من انه الارضيه الصلبه من ما
يربطنا من اواصر المصاهره
[موسيقى]
التواصل الثقافي
هو الذي
يعطينا ثقه بانه هذا المسار سوف يصل الى
بشكل قريب وسريع سوف يصل الى
الغرض والنتيجه المرجوه من كل من البلدين
في اطار
استعاده زخم هذه العلاقات وقوتها
تتطلع ان شاء الله
باستمرار التواصل والتنسيق مع معالي
الوزير ايضا فتح قنوات التواصل فيما بين
الاجهزه الحكوميه
واستمرار عملنا بشكل كثيف حتى نصل الى ماء
نتطلع اليه سويا من
استعاده هذه العلاقه الهامه تحدثنا
بما هو
الخطوه
التي
تؤدي يؤدي اليها هذا المسار وتكون مؤشر
تناولنا الكافه القضايا
ووجود الارضيه والتفاهم المشترك وهي امر
لا اقول انه شكلي ولكنه دال على
انتهاء
المسار
وجود القدر من التفاهم فيما يتعلق بخافه
مناحي العلاقه وهو توقيت استعاده العلاقات
على مستوى السفراء في اي مرحله لم تنقطع
العلاقه الدبلوماسيه فيما بين البلدين
مجرد كان هناك
العمل من خلال قائمه باعمال في كل منهما
ولكن العلاقاتيه كانت دائما قائمه وهناك
تمثيل لمصر في او قرى وتمثيل لاقره في
القاهره
العمل على استعاده العلاقات على مستوى
السفراء
في هذا الجزئيه ايضا
وسوف
ناتي اليها في التوقيت الملائم
وفقا
لما تاتي به ياتي به هذا المسار من نتائج
ايجابيه في الحقيقه بدات منذ هذا اللقاء
بان
وجدنا ان هناك رؤيه مشتركه حول عديد من
المواضع سواء فيما يتعلق بكيفيه
اطلاق العلاقات الثنائيه سياسيه واقتصاديا
وايضا اتصالا
بالرؤيه كثير من القضايا الاقليميه وكيفيه
العمل والتنسيق المشترك للوصول الى نتائج
تاتي في صالح مصلحه كل من البلدين مره
اخرى برحب بمعالي وزير الاخ العزيز
واتمنى له اقامه مريحه في القاهره
واتطلع الى استمرار التواصل والتنسيق فيما
بيننا وهذا شرف عظيم وشيء اقدره واتطلع
اليه شكرا جزيلا
صديقي واشكر كل القائمين
اشكر حفاوه الاستقبال
[موسيقى]
سياده وزير الخارجيه سامح شكري بعد هذه
الزياره القصيره
عبر عن سعادتي
وبالتاكيد طبعا زيارته كانت بدافع تحسين
العلاقات بين البلدين
[موسيقى]
ونامل ان تدوم الزيارات
قريبه الى تركيا
[موسيقى]
ونشكر سيادتكم على المساعدات التي قمت
الى هذه
بيعبر عن التضامن ما بين البلدين
[موسيقى]
سياده وزير الخارجيه كان من اول منظر الى
تركيا
وبعد ذلك قامت سياده الرئيس عبد الفتاح
السيسي
بتعزيه رئيس الجمهوريه والاتصال به
خلال الاتصال التليفوني
[موسيقى]
واحب ان اعبر عن سعاده التركيه
بالمساعدات الجاده التي اتت من مصر في هذه
النكبه
نعم لقد جاءت الى تركيا بهدف المساعدات
اربع طائرات
[موسيقى]
ولقد كان لنا فرصه سعيده بمقابله سياده
الوزير في
انطاكيا اسكندرون نشكركم مره اخرى على ما
قدمته
وكما قلتم سياده الوزير فان العلاقات ما
بين تركيا ومصر علاقه تاريخيه
ثقافه مشتركه
[موسيقى]
نود ان نقوي هذه العلاقات ما بين
وبالتاكيد طبعا هذا يحتاج الى مساعده ودعم
من رئيسين سياده الرئيس السيسي والساده
الرئيس اردوغان
[موسيقى]
ونحن نعمل على تسهيل لقاء سياده رئيسيه
الجمهوريه
ولذلك اتينا الى هنا
لنعمل على هذا ونتباحه السويان ما يمكن ان
تقدمه دولتنا وما يمكن ان تقدمه دولتكم
وتحدثنا في ذلك
[موسيقى]
واحب ان اعبر بعد هذا اللقاء القصير ان
كيلانا سعيد بهذا وكلانا مصمم على العمل
على الوصول الى ما نسعى اليه
[موسيقى]
دائما ما نقول ان العلاقات ما بين مصر
وتركيا علاقات مشتركه وقويه حتى في
الفترات التي كان ما بين جهود في العلاقات
مصر لها دورا عظيم في عده قضايا منها
القضايا الفلسطينيه
تقويه العلاقات ما بين الدولتين يجب ان
تنظر كل دوله الى ما يعود على شعبينا
وما يمكن ان يحقق
الاستقرار والنهضه
ولهذا يمكن ان اقول ان
لتقويه العلاقات الثنائيه اهميه عظمى
بما يعود على شعبينا ودولتين ومنطقتنا
[موسيقى]
ومن هنا يمكن ان اقول ان اعتبار من الان
فصاعدا
سيتم اتخاذ خطوات ايجابيه نحو تحقيق هذا
وبكل طرف على كل طرف بعض الاجراءات التي
سيقوم ساعيا الى تاديتها
في هذه الفتره نبحث ما هو على كل دوله ان
تقدمه بهذا ولا هذا لابد ان يقوم بيننا
لقاءات ومشاورات
دائما الى عمل هذا من خلال لقائنا على
طاوله واحده على مستوى الوزراء
على مستوى الهيئات على مستوى الوزارات
وسيكون
[موسيقى]
على ننتاق المحلي وعلى نطاق المنطقه التي
نعيش فيها
بالتاكيد قد بحثنا في ذلك
[موسيقى]
عن بعض القضايا التي تخص سوريا ايراك
وايران
الحدود
وخاصه القضايا الموجوده في الصومال
لقد كان لقائنا حول كل هذا
[موسيقى]
ان نحسن كل العلاقات على مستوى
المجلس الشعب
[موسيقى]
ونتمنى بالتاكيد ان تزيد
ويعود هذا
على
دولتنا واحب ان نعبر ان هناك استثمارات
قويه جدا
ما بين الدولتين
ونحن نحس كل شركتنا على زياده ومضاعفه
الاستثمار
في دولتكم
وايضا احب ان اعبر ان هذا هو موضوعنا
وقضيتنا وهو الحس حث هذه الشركات على
مضاعفه الاستثمارات
اذا كان اللقاء على مستوى وزارتين فانا
اود ان اقول انه سيكون في
ايام المقبله تعاون من قبل الهيئات
والوزارات الاخرى بما يحقق التعاون
التضامن
من اكبر الصادرات التي تقوم بها مصر هي
تركيا احب ان اعبر عن نحن اننا ممنونين
وسعداء لهذا
كبيره جدا في تركيا
وهي نقطه لابد ان نلقي الضوء عليها
والامان هو في تقويه وزياده حجم هذا
التعاون
وتوفيد الاواصر
ويجب ان ننمي العلاقه ما بين دولتين
ونحس ايضا سياحه
عدد السياحه الذين ياتون الى مصر وعدد
السياحه الذين ياتون من مصر الى تركيا
لابد ان يزيد
واتمنى ان شاء الله ان تزيد
وتنمو العلاقات مره اخرى
ونتمنى ايضا ان يتم افتتاح مره اخرى فرع
للمركز
في الاسكندريه كما كان من قبل
حتى ان نفعل كل ما تحدثنا عنه لابد ان
نعمل سويا وبشكل جاد في الايام المقبله
في منتهى المحبه حتى يحدث هذا اشكر اخي
سياده وزير الخارجيه سامح شكري مره اخرى
على تعبيره دائما عن سعيه لتقويه هذه
العلاقات مثل ما نفكر وعن وعده باننا
سنعمل على تقويه هذا واشكركم ايضا على حسن
استضافتكم
[موسيقى]
وكما قلت بسيادتكم فان لقائنا كان بهدف
كيف يمكن لنا ان ننمي العلاقات ما بين
دولتين
ونتمنى ان تزيد اللقاءات على المستوى
السياسي والدبلوماسي نشكركم جدا
سؤالين لكل وزير
نبدا ارجو من كل مراسل يذكر اسمه والجهه
التي يعمل بها
استاذ احمد
شكرا جزيلا يا فندم احمد جمعه من صحيفه
وموقع اليوم السابع المصري سؤالي لمعالي
وزير خارجيه تركيا مولود
نلاحظ تطورا في تطبيع العلاقات الثنائيه
ما بين تركيا ومصر خلال الفتره الماضيه ما
هي رؤيه الجانب التركي للخطوات المقبله
على مسار تطبيع هذه العلاقات بين البلدين
وما هي الخطوات التي نتوقعها خلال الفتره
المقبله وسرعه تنفيذ هذه الخطوات شكرا
جزيلا
اشكركم جدا
احب ان اعبر ان محادثتنا كانت بيني وبين
سياده الوزير سامح شكري
وبحثنا فيها كيف يمكن ان نطور هذه
العلاقات وفي اي المجالات يمكن
ان نستثمر مساعينا
[موسيقى]
ونود ان نعبر ايضا
اننا قد بحثنا في تنميه قطاع الطاقه ما
بين دولتين
وتقويه التجاره
وفتح المسارات والمباحثات الدبلوماسيه كما
كانت من قبل
تشاورنا في القضايا
الموجوده في المنطقه
كانت مشاورتنا حول القضايا السياسيه
والقضايا التي تخص المنطقه التي نحيا فيها
لقد عاشت العلاقات ما بين دولتين فتره من
البرود
ولذلك فنحن موجودون الان
لتقويه واعاده العلاقات الى مسارات القوي
[موسيقى]
سين وسيكون ان شاء الله ثلاث
تطبيقات عسكريه ما بين دولينا
[موسيقى]
سيكون تقويه واعاده العلاقات من السياسه
حتى قطاع التعليم
وسنسعى دائما وسويا
لندفع
الاجراءات نحو هذا المسار اشكركم مره اخرى
اود ان اقول ان اهم ما في الموضوع ان يكون
لنا اراده وعزم
سياسي
ونود ان نقول سيكون هناك لقاءات وراء
بعضها البعض
وانا احب ان اعبر عن سعادتي مما بقى له
سيادته الوزير ووعداء به
شكرا سؤال تلفزيون تي ار تي التركي
تركيا
في هذه الفتره سيكون
دعوه لسيادتكم في ايام المقبله لرجال
الاعمال الاتراك
وفي الفتره
التي بعد ذلك ما هي خطوات التي يمكن ان
تقوم بها
لتقويه العلاقات
وبشكركم مره اخرى
وكانوا تحدثت هناك رغبه
لتطوير العلاقات
واستعاده زخمها على كافه الاصعده سواء
كانت السياسيه او الاقتصاديه تاكيد انه
العلاقات الاقتصاديه لها مكانه مهمه ورغم
فطور معالي الوزير في العلاقات وقد حرست
دوما يتم التاثير على النطاق العلاقات
الاقتصاديه بين البلدين بل بالعكس انه
خلال السنوات الماضيه نمت هذه العلاقه حتى
وصل التبادل التجاري فيما بيننا الى حوالي
تسعه مليار دولار وهذا
مقدار مهم للبلدين بالاضافه الى
الاستثمارات التركيه في مصر اللي بلغت 2.5
مليار دولار خلال السنوات الماضيه ايضا
والتواجد
رجال الاعمال
والصناعات التركيه على الاراضي المصريه
كانت
رعايه واهتمام لانها تعود بنفع متبادل على
كل من الناحيه الاقتصاديه حيه العماله في
مصر وبالتالي كان هناك دائما اهتمام
ورعايه
للاشقاء من تركيا في اقامه مشروعاتهم على
الاراضي المصريه وفي استمرار تنميه
العلاقات التجاريه في شتى المنتجات صناعيه
وغير صناعيه في اطار التكامل
والتبادل التجاري نحن نعمل على
ونتصور انه بالتاكيد مع تطبيع العلاقه مع
استعاده
زخامها وقوتها انه هذا سوف يؤدي الى مزيد
من الاهتمام من قبل رجال الاعمال في
البلدين
لتوسيع رقعه الاستفاده المتبادله ومن هنا
كانت لقاء دوله رئيس وزراء مصر مع مجموعه
المستثمرين اللي يستمع الى افكارهم
بالنسبه للتطوير نشاطهم في مصر
يتعرضوا اليه من
عقبات عمل على تشغيلها
وسوف نستمر في اطار توظيف الاليات اللي
هيستعيد حيويتها ونشاطها سواء كانت مجالس
رجال الاعمال سواء كان التواصل على مستوى
مسؤوليه البلدين المعنيين بالنطاق
الاقتصادي
والغرف التجاريه
بحيث تتوسع رقعه التعاون وتنستكشف مجالات
جديده
تعود بالمصلحه المشتركه
لمصر خطط لاستمرار جذب الاستثمار وتسليل
العقبات وتوفير
[موسيقى]
اجراءات التحفيزيه
لجذب المستثمرين وتوفير الفرص لهم
والامكانيات من خلال اجراءات مبسطه
وبالتاكيد سوف يستفيد منها المستثمرين
والرجال الاعمال الاتراك خلال الفتره
القادمه كل المجالات مفتوحه في اطار هذه
الاراده المشتركه لتنميه العلاقات
واستعاده قوتها
ونرى في هذا التواصل على مستوى
القطاعات المختلفه وخاصه القطاع الاعمال
فرصه طيبه لتاكيد الروابط القائمه فيما
بين البلدين
ناخد سؤال اخر
الاستاذه سوزي الجنيدي اتفضلي
شكرا
سؤال سياده الوزيرين لاحظنا انه سعادتكم
تطرقتم في خلال الكلام انه تم البحث عدد
من الموضوعات الاقليميه الاقليميه
والدوليه هل ممكن نلقي مزيدا من الضوء على
هذه الموضوعات وايضا ما هي فرصه تقارب بين
البلدين حول تلك الموضعات في الفتره
القادمه شكرا
كما تتحدث معالي الوزير فنحن بحثنا
بالاضافه الى العلاقات الثنائيه الاوضاع
الاقليميه سواء كانت متصله بالقضيه
الفلسطينيه
بالاوضاه كنا معكم في متابعه لهذا المؤتمر
الصحفي المشترك لوزير خارجيه مصر وتركيا
وهو الاول من نوعهم منذ 11 سنه وزيره
خارجيه مصر سامح شكري مشاهدينا قال انه
ناقش مع نظيره التركي مساله التطبيع
الكامل للعلاقات مع تركيا واكد ان
العلاقات بين القاهره وانقره وممتده
وتاريخيه شكري اضاف ايضا انه اجرى مع
نظيره التركي وباحثات مهمه وشفافه اما
وزير خارجيه تركيا فقال من جهته انه يجري
العمل على تسهيل عقد لقاء بين السيسي
واردوغان وانه اعتبارا من الان ستتخذ
تركيا خطوات لعوده العلاقات لطبيعتها مع
مصر
ايضا مشاهدينا ان مصر كانت
من اولى الدول التي وقفت مع تركيا في
كارثه الزلزال
ونكتفي بهذا القدر مشاهدينا ونتابع معكم
في سياق النشاط المقبله تفاصيل هذه
الزياره